I don't think you can say we can say
that because it's important to
understand the global linkages and
perhaps allowing Lehman Brothers to fail
as an example of why you cannot make
these decisions very quickly nor can you
make them very light in a very light
manner not only do are there such close
linkages and significant linkages in
terms of size that could could really
dramatically affect or cause a collapse
of the whole banking system which would
not be a good thing were there to be a
decision to to allow some hedge funds to
fail for example or some investor to
fail so I actually don't think so i
think it's a much more it needs a much
more considered approach i know people
are very anxious and very keen to see
decisions be made quickly but i think
it's really important to understand that
we now also know that what can happen to
a system if a bank is allowed to spare
or a big financial institutions about to
fail from the experience of seeing
Lehman Brothers fail so I actually think
that you know we would like to see more
regulation we would like to see some
changes to the system that from where it
was in the past but I don't think that
we should get too hung up on allowing a
specific hedge fund or hedge funds to
fan
you